I've had bigger disappointments in my  life much bigger disappointments I think  people expect me to handle it the way  they would yeah so they think I'd be  like in the shadows right now like  sad and what yeah I'm like it's fine  this is life even if you had like  destroyed me five rounds and then killed  me at the end of flat like me I'd have  down spirits of course I'm human it  sucks to lose don't get me wrong I love  winning I love winning but I'm still  grateful like what a life I wonder if  there's this weird Silver Lining to A  Moment Like This though it's incredibly  disappointing you also get to see how  much people care about her about yeah  I'm getting so much A lot of people are  like oh he won the fans back I'm like my  real fans never left yeah I'm sure so  yeah inspired by you and proud of you  bro it's so amazing  you don't understand you don't  understand  thank you thank you this is good  honestly I'm fine